[Laughter]
it'll be like star trek every even
numbered
what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we are here to watch lord
of the rings the rings of power episode
4 today johnny how's it going i'm good
how are you sir doing well alrighty gang
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated use the power of the ring or
the sauron or whatever you want to say
to subscribe and click that bell episode
one a little bit meh to us episode two
good three more on the downside four you
gotta go in with an open mind though and
hope for the best so let's see what goes
on today either way we'll be honest when
this episode's done you want to catch
our full introduction watch along as we
sync up with the time code that is at
our patreon page for super sexy rejects
thank you to all who support us over
there and of course team of prepper
thank you for helping send it down these
highlights let's swing an action
[Music]
what name have you chosen for her
early now
may numenor's strength
arise in thee
her wisdom
guide thy steps
that's a good omen sometimes our island
just needs a stretch
that's reassuring
[Music]
wow
it's a hell of a stretch your island is
having right now
[Laughter]
[Music]
we just got to know this island here
ireland is going to the chiropractor
right now perfect day queen regent
is only trying to be clever
cleverness
for men of small ambition
i'd much rather it if you were wise
my son
now that's clever
and wise
the queen's either blind or an elf lover
just like her father
oh boy i swear that elven hands will
never take nuno's helm
she will remain as always a kingdom of
men
she
will remain a kingdom of men
you know gender is a spectrum
[Applause]
90 of these background extras have no
idea what's going on
just put your hands up
you're excited you're you're roused
i call on you to finish the task left
undone to reforge the alliance between
numenor and elves
and fight with me
to save the men of the southlands before
sauron claims their lands for his own
he's like we didn't rehearse this
[Laughter]
i i don't know if she's off-road now
castaway grasping for a handhold in a
tempest there's a tempest in me
and it will not be quelled by you regent
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh no cadets
they need to get a handle on that thing
i've seen you ease that halyard proper
100 times
that was deliberate
you're off the sea god
oh no
oh what a shame
you just set our whole lives on fire
i did everything i was supposed to do to
earn it and what did you do
what have you ever done but brood and
blubber about your debt
is that him
rest my child
it's nice to see someone actually mourn
an orc
even orcs have customs
i'm being serious i actually really like
it
no totally 100
why do the orcs call you father
sonic
sanic
to untangle it all
would orbit require the creation of a
new world
but that is something only the gods can
do and
i am no god
at least
not yet
not yet
go to the men who've taken refuge in the
old watchtower
deliver to them a message
what message
[Music]
sauron is back
sauron was here
i'm not going in there there might be
more food
all right i'll go
wow there's dead animals the show is
more violent than i expected it to be
they come out when the sun's gone
i just straight up abandon him yep
no
young blood
would you get that
buddy
dude
nobody speaks silly's found
oh my god
[Laughter]
i think that's a terrible idea
[Music]
he's not very good at
keeping it down
doing all this as loud as possible they
keep putting me off
one would almost think it's suspicious
are you suggesting durham's got himself
a weak girlfriend there is none other
than you m'lady i know
who'd have him
[Laughter]
if during his mining quartz why would he
leave without taking his chiseling axe
and why would you be preparing his
favorite meal if he's gone to a chasm
that takes two full days to descend
sherlock holmes over here because the
courts he's mining isn't chiseled it is
pride i am making moletail stew because
it needs a wee while to set before he's
home
dwarven climbers like my husband can
make the descent to quartz chasm in just
a few hours
thank
you would not mess with her
nope
battle of wits right there
just hope he believed me he's not easily
taken in that health certainly not
we're making good progress in the old
mine
[Music]
no
the old mine below the mirror
you lost
very clever elf
a night
what is this place yeah really expect me
to believe you do not know but this was
not the true reason he sent you here to
begin with you want it for yourself
during want watch
maybe the material it is made of hanta
mountain
you'll never breathe so much as a
whisper of what i'm about to tell you to
another living soul dwarven anger
outlives even elven memory
break your promise
i swear on the memory of my father
harder than iron as weaponry it would
best our proudest blades
might be dearer than gold
may
i'm sorry i break my oath
in our tongue great glitter
and you're something like me throughout
me through no no it would be
me
yeah
i know i know that [ __ ]
reference
cut a softball
keep it
oh
talking about friendship you're going to
piss off your father
giving it to a bloody elf you're it now
there's four dwarves down
they dug too deep
you do well to identify what it is that
your opponent most fears
and exploit it
no give them a means of mustering it
so that you
can muster them
so by your standards i am in this cell
because i have yet to identify what the
queen most fears
a flooding
all of a sudden she throws you in a cell
why
i asked her to fight for your people
but that wasn't what provoked her anger
was it
i demanded to speak with her
father master her father
a teddy's girl
i wasn't advised that i can't very well
let her leave
you got
dismissed
got us all dismissed
i just ruined my friends lives
shamed our family name
oh you're gonna do much worse
oh my dude no idea apologies your
majesty for the intrusion
but i no longer answers to that
person of troops who waits outside to
escort you to your ship
you would be wise to go
[Music]
willingly like john hurt i know
he announced plans to renew relations
with the elves the people rebelled
that first night
as all numenor slept
he brought me here
oh my god
seven seeing stones there once were
this episode's filled with things i know
[Laughter]
best one yet
[Music]
[Music]
cool
[Music]
share the same nightmare
i don't think she was having a nightmare
in the beginning i believe she was using
that and she was remembering it
it came to her back in a nightmare but
fair enough
i'm incorrect
my decision is final a decision based in
fear
choose not the path of fear
but that of faith
let numenor fight alongside the elves
once more
build each other up
faith may bind one heart
but it is to find a threat from which to
hang a kingdom
i'm sorry
sugar
let's give it a minute questio
you should be right behind
that me kid
come on
terrible hiding spot
order the best because no one's got it
[Laughter]
i like this shot it's like a stealthy
video game escape level yeah
yeah they still think the boys just run
around there yep all these hours yep
he wouldn't have gone far
he wouldn't have fled
say grab your items
yeah just like a video game love it
you need a health pack bro
it's a really well done shot
oh you knew it
losing your arm we'll loosen your lips
keep going
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
that did give me a
little bit of a nippy chill there
[Music]
oh no
yes
it's boring
get to the light
[Music]
have faith in the light i cannot stop
thinking that if you'd not gone down
there
durian might have been in that shaft
when it i just pulled out the last one
alive
sometimes i wish i could tell him
exactly what i think of him i would be
only too happy to hear any judgment so
long as it granted me the opportunity to
have but one more conversation with my
father do not waste
what time you have left with yours
that's a good speech
got done bud
how is it that you and my husband met
there were three trolls and it was i who
saved him
you wouldn't remember your face if
you're gazing in a mirror and i came
upon him in the forest he was in the
midst of dodging their mallet blow
it was a battle crank the screams were
so high-pitched i thought it was a child
[Laughter]
now i hear more of the story
forgive me father
i was proud
and stubborn
and i was wrong
oh no oh okay i thought it was the worst
that happened
forever
am i with you my son
sometimes in anger most of all
there is nothing to forgive
i thought he was gonna say some really
harsh things
like i was geared up to just cut
is on the inside you don't take it
just like you took that hilt
from the bar
feet
you know what i speak
do you know what it is the beautiful
servant
he was lost
which
you save your strength
you'll need it
so what's coming
what's coming
everything you say leads to more
questions man
we found it
it's in the tower
okay i
really like this episode
it's probably the best one so far
it's pretty engaging
it'll be like star trek every even
numbered yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
people will be relieved
they'll be gathering soon in the court
and in the plaza to hear your
announcement
burning effigy is shaped like elves
what's the announcement
you know that everything's great
no war is brewing
the elf is gone
[Music]
it's happening anyway
it's like a time machine
no matter what you do to try and stop it
i would neither command
nor invite you to any danger i myself
would not face
and so i've decided to personally escort
the elf back to middle earth
to aid our mortal brethren
who are now besieged in the southwest
your queen has laid bare her intent
our ships will depart in 10 days oh boy
i will serve
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
well done
wowie all right not just saying it i
have nothing to gain if i like an
episode or something
you gotta win the internet back
when who backed the internet
no matter who you win you'll lose just
as many people so
all i all you have left to do is be
honest if you like an episode or not
and yeah i would say that this is my
favorite one so far of uh all four that
we've gotten because uh
i was genuinely interested in every
storyline they were cutting to i cannot
say that about any of the other episodes
like this one i was actually it was easy
to pay attention to
um it was engaging
at times the emotional parts were
a little bit more swelling than i had uh
expected it to be and even by the very
end of it when they are uniting
i was like hell yeah cool yeah oh my god
i'm actually
i'm anticipating yeah
what do you know what an experience is
because it's because it's starting to
feel like an actual experience to me
and i feel like it's just this has been
like you know what i would like in this
experience too have you guys seen the
movie cloud outlet have you seen it i
have not okay cloud atlas is cutting
between
and maybe a lot of people don't share
this opinion like me but cloud atlas i
remember watching it the first half of
that movie was very frustrating and very
difficult to sit through because it's
cutting between so many different story
lines
and they're very and it's not like this
because the cloud alice is like
different genres per story line and and
you have like same actors playing
different roles and just a little much
and they're very and they're just
completely different stories
and
eventually it around the middle like oh
you know i'm starting starting to enjoy
this and eventually i was like oh this
is really enjoyable it was really great
it starts to
smooth itself out once you get uh
acquainted i didn't think it would take
like four episodes but
this uh
we've cut we've checked in with pretty
much every storyline in this one right
except the harford's yeah except the
horror foots they're the thing that's
holding this show back
it's funny if the episodes that aren't
as good they are the best part but then
they are very sparingly used in the best
episodes so far
they mentioned yeah the the you know the
starfall the the the man of earth but
that's about it yeah
yeah but everything else no no i think i
like the horror foots for the most part
and
uh but for the most part they cut to
everyone's storyline and i was i loved
the conversations between forgive me for
not did you commit to memory the name of
the queen john uh
not yet
queen regents
we have the actual credits pulled up
right here at the end episode uh i like
the conversations between the queen and
galadriel because galadriel's
note starts to
sound like the way she talks sounds like
kind of repetitive after a certain point
but i felt like her scenes actually
allowed for some
a little bit of layers with it even the
scene when she's in prison and she's
talking with
the
prisoner
what's his name
something cool bruh
bro bro
brown bronwyn no bronwyn's the lady god
damn it bronwyn's theo's problem oh [ __ ]
so many different names
go
forward find it
get it get it no no
no no no you're not catching it
hal the brand the how brand they how the
hell brand okay we did it all right so
even the conversation hog run where you
do see her
um
you know
as stubborn as she is she's starting to
look she she is uh learning and then
even that conversation when she does
talk with the queen
with what i've always called saruman's
ball
stone
when she's talking with him and you get
more of that you know they have that
line in there earlier
of you know cleverness versus wisdom and
or versus being wise and and her
instilling some wisdom into the middle
of negotiating for a specific thing
yeah i i thought that was nice to get
like a shade of that galadriel and and
see more of the wise elvish side of her
one usually what we've been seeing is
just kind of like the brooding angry
yeah kind of the warrior
yeah and uncompromising what's some like
repetitive delivery in the way she talks
but this one i i quite enjoyed her and
and uh still to me elrond and durin are
are the best parts of of the show like
whenever we're with them it's
even with elrond's speech that he's
talking about his dad
i thought that was very touching and i'm
like i don't know his dad i don't even
know this guy i don't even know who this
character probably heard his name off
hand
at one point or another but yeah but the
history of the effect that his dad had
on him and then conversation of how he's
using it to instill again some wisdom
to during during a time that is quite
merciless for him and feeling like he's
not worthy enough not good enough and in
a state of anger that that was a very
moving speech and everything with uh
aaron dear showing up being a badass and
who is most likely sauron unless the
show's doing one massive mislead who is
most likely sauron
i i thought it had a a really striking
mood and tone and
yeah i thought you know what it was too
like this this was uh
i felt like we actually had like
character stuff yeah i felt like
character driven it felt like there was
character uh detail and character layers
with the plot stuff moving forward it
found it seems like they finally managed
to do both at the same time instead of
just like dumping exposition into the
like backstory explanation while talking
to each other yeah and sometimes people
justify that as character driven
dialogue but it's really not and here i
i thought
like something more character-driven to
me is like those conversations with
galadriel and the queen and galadriel
and halbron
you know those moments felt like oh this
is like good character narrative for
collateral things to learn yeah no
totally it's
it does well to push her out of her
comfort zone and that in and of itself
creates a certain
character moment because yeah you have
to watch her overcome an obstacle
uh and one that requires you to you know
kind of look within and also look at you
know that whole thing about what does
she fear look
at you know what she's up against and
and don't necessarily use it to exploit
her but see if you can you know look
past that and maybe offer some kind of
aid and i feel like that speaks to you
know the humanity within anybody but
through that you know it's i feel like
indirectly calling
with galadriel up until this point you
know as much as i like uh more fifth
clark's performance generally there is
kind of like a
there's that one one
this happened to me a lot in the hobbit
movies too and i feel like it is often
the pitfall in fantasy where yeah it's
like the character dialogue becomes i'm
just talking a lot about my mission and
and the mission that i'm on and that's
my focus but yeah you you actually have
to watch her kind of navigate a social
situation and step beyond her comfort
zone
and i thought that was that made for a
really satisfying turn when by the end
the petals start to fall
and the queen actually does
offer the aid and step into the conflict
and you know bring that you know allied
power
you know and i thought they
you know spread that out in a way where
it felt actually satisfying and like it
built upon something and you across this
episode we're seeing various aspects of
culture whether that be on rest in the
city of newman or just with the ground
level characters or you're seeing into
the actual rituals and and uh
you know practices that even the most
you know scummy creatures on this earth
have in the orcs or even with the
dwarves when they're doing the sort of
ceremony to bring out uh the the lost
miners like there are so many things
that i think
blend over nicely
with that plot stuff basically yeah uh
and i like the i like the way they're
fleshing out a lot of this it's it's
starting to become something that
is actually becoming you know what i've
never said with the thing that was i
could just never say prior to this
episode was i never found anything
compelling and i think there are
compelling qualities too here every
everything with durham and
durham and his father i thought was uh
really interesting too
like there is a complexity there
and this game that durham is sort of
playing with elrond where it doesn't
kind of see
he there's always a a guard up and every
time you think that guard is completely
let down it's not that there is always a
rising suspicion that there's something
more there and you
i do root for their friendship like i i
root for them to give them like i feel
like it'll run somewhere like that scare
me i feel like you didn't come here to
come here with an agenda and a favor but
he's pretty honest with you you know so
i i root for that friendship uh quite a
bit i like the queen a lot
honestly i mean i said it last episode
when the queen was introduced i was like
here we go another stoic ass character
yeah and i i i think she
she is okay whoever this actress is i
don't i never
maybe i've seen her work before i don't
know cynthia a day robinson
i think sh the the way that at least it
might have something to do with the
director of this episode i i'm like i
want to make this just a conversation
like what did this episode work
because it might have something to do
with the way this episode in particular
was directed but there was something
about capturing the mood and then the
expression like you know when she's
having those uh those visions and the
way she when she fears something i'm
like she really does sell the fear in
her eyes and she does sell
without over emoting being torn between
what to do even in her first
conversation with galadriel i thought
was really well done and even fleshing
out the city of
uh
numenor
uh the the political angles of of how
the society there feels about
elves
it's starting to build a world that i am
truly that i feel an emotion towards now
something that has an emotional pull
more than just facts about what's going
on it started it's starting to click for
me i mean i'm hoping it kind of stays
this way yeah
he builds upon it you know
uh but as it's going i mean what other
storylines were there oh the the sun
with theo i thought
that you know
it's love how whenever they go back to
that home it's gonna be a tent horror
film yeah
yeah uh with theo i i liked how he
the way that sequence was captured it
felt very much like a video game um as
he's like sneaking around and
like you hide behind the wall the
character could probably see you from if
they just like looked a little bit like
if you don't make a noise you'll be fine
yeah but but in terms of
obscure vision in video game levels it
worked for me
i like the way that sequence was done
and the other thought that that this
this episode in particular really
solidified for me
other than a couple of shots where it
feels like an actor in a costume like
literally at the most nitpicky a couple
of shots
if so you could just pretty much ignore
me saying that because
i actually think the way they flesh out
the uh the orcs in this show is better
than the movies
by quite a bit
like i think they they they the
personality they provide that they know
i mean there is a certain like orcs or
who's going to be you know yeah
yeah but they actually feel threatening
and when they show up in hordes you know
it had me for a brief moment admittedly
just a tiny moment but briefly when
aaron dear theo and uh
mom who were
in the woods i was like [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] mom might get killed here you know
yeah yeah totally because the when the
orcs aren't that big of droves like that
big of a horde it
it they are kind of scary and you do see
that they are an actual threat they can
kill you and they're not just you know
quantity henchmen while we wait for
something bigger and better to show up
they can show up in a mob but in this
show like especially in the in the
hiding scene with theo it does feel like
they are all individuals sort of gnarled
up characters and whatnot like even
though there is that sort of grimy
quality still
yeah there's something that feels a
little more real and a little more alive
about them and i think too again seeing
that brief moment at the camp when uh
you know they're laying that one guy to
rest i think even just that one beat
really adds a lot to just the
i don't know weird communal like even
though they are evil ostensibly they are
still like a group communal trying to
subsist and trying to find their land in
this
you know realm of realm and like
everyone
thus far is being displaced to some
degree i mean the harfords are nomadic
but then you have you know uh bronwyn's
village who is now you know forced to
flee and forced to find some place new
and you've got numenor looking like
destruction maybe imminent and things
like that and so even though they are
completely on the opposite side there's
still something like
underlying that makes them just feel
more yeah alive then oh here comes the
big scary guys and i feel like too the
way they use the darkness that comes
with them like when they got back to the
light i was like oh it's not nighttime
actually in this episode and i thought
the um you know that went from night in
today yeah
well i thought they left the shadow i
thought it's like the shadow consumed
the village to such a point that like or
either way the way they used the shadow
when it sets in that first time when the
sun is still out like it does feel
ominous and a little more palpable in a
way than just like ooh a mystical force
you know it feels
more desolate and that horror movie
kind of tone feels like it gets an
actual transition motivated by the
surroundings
wait are you right about that i'm trying
i want to make sure i'm understanding
this i'm not sure because he gets back
with the cart and it's like nighttime
right yeah and the watch yeah yeah it's
pretty sure it's night time when he gets
back yeah so i mean i guess it's like
the next morning or something yeah it's
like a dawn when they get out of the out
of the
shadow into the light yeah so there is
kind of they're both overlapping
the shadow overlaps with the day into
the night into the next day
yeah
um so i
i think uh i think theo is
what they're building up with theo i i
feel like you know they play if they
keep building upon it properly it could
lead to something what could potentially
be quite heartbreaking sure because she
really cares about that her kid
you know she really loves that kid and
he wants so badly to help and is always
getting interesting
she's just like a freaking angsty little
ass yeah so and now he's got the
ultimate
angst machine
yeah and i think i like i like i find
that compelling that amongst this camp
of you know the the people who have
fleed from this village
that uh what was it the barkeep the in
the innkeeper um how
he actually had a connection to i gotta
keep asking you for words what is the
name that they're they're calling it
oh the the hilt the blade is it yeah i
guess it's just a hilt right yeah
because
yeah um
that he had the connection to the hilt
and it's like this is our little secret
here like that that is fascinating oh my
god that this evil was lurking here
already amongst with someone else and
now he feels like he's got a companion
and when the theo has no idea what's
going on and you should probably say
something
it feels like finally by this episode
we've got all the main
all the main places set so now we can
actually start developing each camp of
the story and the geography between them
feels more palpable too
yeah i think the one storyline that uh
i'm waiting to that i'm only interested
in only because i know the end result
is sealed
but what they're currently doing i i'm
not
that into
i like the dad with alan deal is that
nasa
um
yeah i like the dad a lot i think that
dad brings a lot of history and uh so
he's great to watch and everyone he's
bouncing off of he's feels like a
traditionally
stage play actor something like really
great about the way he is yeah um the
presence he provides it feels very
natural with the world
uh
yeah but it's sealed himself i i feel
like even some of the way they
orchestrate the dialogue surrounding him
seems to be you know let's go with him
yeah yeah
yeah i feel like it's for me a seal door
is most interesting because of everybody
else around him in his story like
whether it's elendil or his sister or
the two guy like the two sailors who he
is discharged with i was pretty engaged
by that alone yeah um and i thought that
at least made for a nice turnaround at
the end where they are the ones who are
like we will volunteer and then they
kind of inspire him like there are
little notes there but yeah
it is
i think you hit it on the head it's like
the one even though there's a lot of
stories that hark into certain
archetypes and certain outcomes that one
is so obvious because you know it's so
important where he goes
um so yeah i'm waiting for that to
settle or to have some kind of real
character beyond
i feel like a lot of his character beats
thus far have been pretty general for
what his journey is you know he's he
dreams of exploring and you know he's
trying to satisfy expectations and
that's fine but i i would like to
see that character open up a bit because
even with like our endear like he's
very stoic very quiet but in those
moments like when he is talking to
adar
uh uh the character they call father
like there is you you i don't know
there's something compelling even though
he is so kind of stoic and quiet well
he's a great actor he is he's he
i've said it since this first episode
like he's great he he really even in the
third episode which i thought was really
dull
i thought i thought he was great yeah
because
you can see you can he he has that that
rare it's not common amongst actors
where you can see what he's thinking
without him having to say it it's really
difficult to find an actor who can do
such a thing
like his scene with
i'm just going to call him sorrow it's
probably sorry all right so his team
would sauron um
you know when he has that blade and you
could tell like
he's scared he's he's on the defense he
might want to fight but he knows he'll
lose he's he doesn't even know who this
person is yeah he hasn't he's not even
sure who this is but he knows something
very like he has to be very
intent on this moment like the way he
succumbs to what is the message you can
just feel that that pain of defeat and
law and losing yeah yeah in that very
moment like his choice like that the
scene there in general was it was a
great tense scene it was a really well
done scene
and uh i like the build up of this guy
who's probably sauron
like it is right like who else would it
be yeah
well
even again back to the orcs though
really quick back to the orcs like him
i feel like if
in the movies at least you know i can't
attest to the books but i feel like in
the movies it would have just been like
another [ __ ] orcas that you know yeah
they wouldn't have cared at all yeah but
but i like the connection uh that he has
when he is like gives a mercy kill yeah
um
and and he stays connected
and and is like the way the the with the
smile with the orc and the eyes the eye
connection they have
of like you're dying it's okay though
you did you did good you're in pieces
yeah like weirdly you're at peace yeah
it feels like you really actually has a
connection and cares and they are his
children and you served us you know yeah
yeah um so i i really uh i really i
really like the the way they've
they think i'd say that about this show
but because like when i saw the amount
of orcs in the trailers it just seemed
like yeah it works okay
yeah how do we get some instant action
or but i think the main thing the one
thing i'd really give this show that i
think they've elevated above the films
is the orcs the orcs are great
yeah no and i hope that that uh trend
continues here and two i think this
episode
i think it's just a testament to like
when it's working then the stylistic
flourishes work because like it's clear
that within the style of this show most
episodes i would expect some kind of
grand sweeping
couple maybe even slow motion sequences
here it was you know the battle in the
woods comes to mind
um and and
those things play a lot better in an
episode like this when you really can be
pulled into
yeah i feel like they have when you get
a character driven or more
character-driven episode like this that
does have moments of levity but also
never
forgetting what the stakes are then you
can sell your more ethereal moments or
your moments that have these grand
sweeping choruses singing beneath them
or these disparate like single voices
singing under them like all those things
that you
you know come across as so
you know huge and again ethereal and of
such circumstance like those they work a
lot better when you can feel both the
life but also the desperate tension of
the circumstances oh yeah like when uh
uh
oh my god [ __ ] names
what is uh durham's wife's name
oh her name is oh uh go back one page
adisa
um
when when disa
uh when they were singing to the
i didn't know what ritual they were
doing and then when you find out that
they're talking to the walls and like
that connection they have to the walls i
yeah
i thought that was really neat
it actually imbued it and again emotion
yeah and not just
like
pretentious
yeah yeah it's a real like this episode
like in the previous episode that might
have played very silly but yeah with
everything working together it really
bolsters moments like that and even the
thing with the mithril uh i thought like
that could easily have been just like oh
there's a thing you know but that even
was like a nice compelling plot point
you get to go oh yeah i know what that
is but at the same time you know the
gravity of that discovery and also the
tension of being like well now because
of this interplay between elrond and
durin the fourth now you know they're at
least for the moment barred from even
pursuing that and so yeah they're
they're they just managed to bring
everything up with like a good
interesting twist on each detail yeah to
make everything a bit more rich i think
yeah man that's a good one good good one
good one the only thing that's not that
interesting to me right now is a sealed
door but i'm giving them holding out
faith yes
uh that it will uh become more
interesting i know some people are
already on board first old work but for
me personally i'm
like
whatever
he looks like
he looks like a friend of mine and it
hasn't gotten past the point where i
just keep seeing my friend you're
friends with tony riverlord that's right
man me and tony go way back bro
um hit me up why don't you return my
calls tony yeah and the sister honestly
this is the sister's
sister's more interesting
like
they are the least interesting
characters out of this episode they
remain this the slightest to me like
even for how little we've seen all brand
over the course of this like he seems
more meaty than his steel door so far
yeah well hall brown's been developing a
personality
he's been hanging out in that prison
cell just rehearsing
how to talk to people
yeah i thought uh who directed this
episode again
i've never heard of this director yeah
yeah
wayne che yep
that's an interesting name
spanish british
asian why do i think spanish yep
mainly just a tv director
doom patrol
i wonder how much you never know how
much creative freedom need like
some of these shows
how much creative freedom i imagine on
lord of the rings it gave me a little
more creative freedom to kind of do some
[ __ ] i would imagine they bring you in
and especially it seems like he's
directed at least a few of these so he's
amazon director of this guy
hunter's wheel of time
yeah at amazon or that abc i forget i
think we always time wasn't amazing
yeah yeah yeah and i feel like yeah
especially on a show that's as expensive
as this i feel like you would get a few
directors together and they would be
part of your think tank yeah
um but all right all right guys cool
good episode
uh i like this one more than the second
so favorite one so far
i hope they stay on this path like the
course they are charting
and i'll make i'm excited for it i'm
excited
all right
well you guys can subscribe click that
bell leave a like last monthly sense of
the patreon
mark leach
now mark i know you've been having an
insanely rough time lately
so we looked up your name on urban
dictionary
and um
i hope you like what it has to say
mark a really funny guy who likes to
make people laugh
this is very accurate even
enduring a hard time he's got a great
soul and it's all he wants to do is help
others good nature good humor he
probably has a meme account and is happy
to send you memes dankest he has really
fluffy hair and amazing brown eyes his
hair
is just like a garnier fructis
commercial with amazing brown eyes
piercing
his smile is so warm it will make you
want to smile whenever he smiles
it becomes like a mirror that makes me
smile it's almost like a horror movie
he's extremely attractive and has really
nice hands oh show me those hands one of
the first things you ever say
when you meet mark leeches like whoa
those hands
i've never seen hands so visually
striking before he makes you happy and
makes you feel better he is my therapy
he's my cure
he's really good at cooking ramen and
loves doggos i don't even know what
doggos are dogs but i love dogs they're
just regular dogs yeah it's just a fun
way of saying dogs oh as mark's a fun
guy you put cooking ramen and doggos in
the same s i thought it was food um i
thought it was like a bacon wrapped
sauce it could be mark also maybe likes
a bacon wrap cooking ramen he's a great
college roommate
he is all the good things in one he will
always be on your mind even when you try
to get him out there you would be the
luckiest girl on earth to have him
because mark is a master in the bedroom
dude i mean
cleaning and keeping frames organized
and closing the drawers
and he will only please you in bed if
requested formally
via email and only once the bet has been
made
that mark is a very organized person and
covers all his tracks
to make sure
he's doing the right thing at all times
make way for those nice hands and trust
me those emails are flooded ooh
flooded with requests banned him off
left and right but he can't just go he
can't respond to everyone there's just
too many requests for mark to be in the
bedroom with them consider yourself
lucky if he gets back to you even if he
just responds even if it's an automated
reply i mean that's probably enough for
most of us to get where we need to go an
automated reply makes me feel special
so mark thank you for doing such a
wonderful human deed my friend you are
the bomb
[Music]